*Bruit de piano*
Zlatan Zlatan Zlatan...
Bonjour, bah moi je m'appelle Eric
J'ai 35 ans et j'suis auteur compositeur pour les
Chants de supporters de foot
Voyez par exemple ce match la,
cette chanson là
"Ohé ohé, ohé.." ça c'est moi qui l'ai écrit
Là ils sont 60 000, 2€ par personne, ils l'ont chanté 3 fois
Bim 360 000€, et le match a même pas commencé.
C'est dire que moi j'ai écrit les plus grand titres
*hum hum, hum hum* On t'encules
ça c'est moi.. ou alors
*hmmmm, hmmm* va niquer ta mère
Bon... Ça c'est moi aussi
*Pooopolopopopoopoooo*.. Pfffff... enculé de White Strips
Vous savez le plus dur c'est pas de composer.. C'est d'écrire
Zlatan va laver tes cheveux parce qu'ils sont trop sales avec le catogan
*marmonne* pfff... Oh putain c'est nul...
Pff... Euh... Un de mes meilleurs titres c'est Paris Paris on t'encule
Au départ moi j'avais écrit ''Paris Paris on t'embête''
Allez-y par exemple faites-le?
Paris, Paris, on t'embête... Ouais ouais c'est vrai qu'il y a pas le...
C'est ça exactement en fait y'a pas.. Y'a ce côté un peu sympa du... Oh t'es con Michel euh... On t'embête.. Tiens j'tai mis une bousculade
Alors que Paris on t'encule on voit tout de suite l'idée principale du truc. Et c'est Paris, ON t'encule! Pas JE t'encule! Donc on est plusieurs!
Imaginez plusieurs personnes sont dans vos fesses? C'est pas agréable :) On est d'accord
3, 4 : *Elles sont où, tes jambes, tes jambes, ... *
Il manque un truc!
*marmonne*
Bon, on refait!
*Elles sont où, tes jambes, tes jambes, fils de pute!
Voilà, c'est ça Gwendal, fils de pute! Voyez?
On vient de faire une belle tarte aux pommes et Gwendal à rajouté la chantilly. Pascal Obispo, lui, utilise beaucoup le mot ''amour'' dans ses chansons
Christophe Maé, lui, utilise plus le mot euh... ''gneaeaaaaa!"
Moi, c'est plus basé un petit peu autour de: ... Ouais, l'anus!
*marmonne* Zlatan... enculé...  enculé... Zlatan, enculé...Ouais!
J'crois qu'on a notre nouveau single!
Et, finalement, qu'est ce que vous pensez du niveau de la ligue 1?
La ligue 1?
Euh, j'connais pas.
Zlatan... Enculé, enculé, enculé, Zlatan enculé!